Leute...
Es ist soweit.
Das hier ist die letzte Science vs. Fiction-Episode.
Ja, das ist krass.
Aber krass waren vor allen Dingen
eure Reaktion auf unsere Ankündigung.
Über 500 Kommentare haben wir bekommen, mit so viel Liebe und Support.
Vielen, vielen, vielen Dank dafür.
Das hat uns im Team hier super viel bedeutet.
Und wer weiß, was hier
auf dem Kanal in Zukunft noch passiert.
Also bitte nicht
deabonnieren, sondern ganz im Gegenteil
jetzt noch mal alle unsere Videos
mit ganz vielen Leuten teilen.
Ihr habt jetzt nochmal Zeit,
das alles durchzubingen.
Da würde ich mich sehr drüber freuen.
Wir wollen in dieser Folge jetzt natürlich
ganz viele von euren Fragen beantworten.
Über 170 habt ihr uns eingeschickt.
Wir können natürlich nicht alle davon
beantworten,
aber wir geben uns Mühe
und haben die mit den meisten Likes
und die, die thematisch zusammenpassen,
in eine Kategorie gepackt.
Und daraus ist eine übelst lange,
sehr, sehr, sehr coole Folge entstanden.
Mit ganz vielen Facts, tollen Expert*innen
und auch weirden Momenten.
In diesem Sinne: Let’s Go!
Im ersten Block dreht sich alles um
Marvel, Disney, Zeichentrick und Anime.
Und zur Abschiedsfolge
mache ich das natürlich nicht alleine,
sondern gemeinsam mit dem Mann,
bei dem alle Superheldinnen
und -helden zu zittern beginnen,
wenn er die Kreide in die Hand nimmt.
Er stellt Monsterformeln auf,
er hat selbst unvorstellbare Moves drauf
und er tanzt,
bis alle Menschen vor Ehrfurcht erstarren.
Henry ist da.
- High Jack!
Henry, hast du bock?
Auf jeden Fall
- Wollen wir direkt mit was Krassem loslegen?
Ich bitte darum.
Das sehen wir hier in dieser Szene aus Spider-Man 2.
sieht ziemlich cool aus, aber
wie viel Kraft müsste Peter Parker hier
dann aufbringen?
- Dafür habe ich schon mal was vorbereitet.
Ohh yeah!
Und zwar sehen wir hier ein Kräftediagramm.
Wir sehen hier Spider-Man.
An dem greifen
die Fäden an, mit den jeweiligen Kräften.
Und jetzt habe ich ein paar Annahmen
getroffen.
Und zwar, dass die Fäden im Mittel
unter einem Winkel von 20 Grad angreifen.
Die Bahn fährt mit 90 km/h
und ich habe die Zeit gestoppt,
bis das Ganze zum Stehen kommt.
Es dauert 39 Sekunden. Jetzt legen wir los.
Ergebnis: Pro Seite würde eine
Kraft von 14.000 Newton ziehen.
Das ist, als ob pro Arm ein Gewicht
von 1,4 Tonnen an dem ziehen würde.
Aber Peter Parker ist auch einer
der stärksten Avengers.
Also müssen wir davon ausgehen,
dass der das einfach wegsteckt.
Hauptsache, du hast nicht wieder
einen falschen Wert vorgegeben.
Wie in unserem Findet Nemo-Short.
Schwamm drüber!
Zu Spiderman passt auf jeden Fall auch
diese Frage:
Das ist gar keine Zukunftsmusik.
Ich habe mal nachgelesen.
Am Institut für Biomaterialien der Uni Bayreuth
wird tatsächlich jetzt schon
künstliche Spinnenseide hergestellt.
Die nutzen da Gentechnik,
um mit einer bestimmten Bakterienart
ganz bestimmte Proteine
der Spinnenseide zu synthetisieren.
Dann kann man mehrere Proteine nehmen,
die aneinander hängen
und das ergibt dann quasi einen Faden.
Wenn man dann mehrere
dieser Fäden zusammen spinnt,
dann hat man so was wie ein Spider-Man-Garn hier.
Ich hab mal nachgerechnet.
Wenn man diese Spinnenseide technisch
irgendwie hoch skalieren könnte,
dann würde die auf jeden Fall halten
und Spidi könnte sich also tatsächlich
easy peasy durch New Yorks
Häuserschluchten schwingen.
Ich finde es schon ein ziemlich starkes
politisches Statement von Marvel.
Ziemlich autoritär, oder?
- Krass, wie Orwell “1984”.
Bei der nächsten Frage, Henry, ist egal, ob wir über Spider-Man reden
oder über Batman, Hauptsache
es sind ordentlich Muckis im Spiel.
Ich habe ja mit Kampfsport gar nichts am Hut.
- Sieht man.
Aber ich erinnere mich an unsere Mortal Kombat-Folge.
Da hat Boxtrainer Ferhat, dir ordentlich eine geballert.
Ja, und Ferhat sagt,
die müssen sich auf jeden Fall
zurückhalten und höllisch aufpassen,
wo genau sie hinhauen.
Also auf jeden Fall sollte man im Nahkampf darauf achten.
Zum Beispiel Kehlkopf ist extrem gefährlich.
Auch Nasenbein, Trommelfell,
die Ohren, das Gleichgewichtsorgan.
Das ist extrem sensibel.
Dann so was wie die Schläfe
oder auch die Kinnspitze,
wo die Blutbahnen zum Gehirn verlaufen,
wo dann die Lichter
ganz schnell ausgehen können.
Und dann kommen wir noch weiter
zum Körper,
zum Beispiel zur Leber
oder auch zum Solarplexus,
wo man die Luft wegnehmen kann.
Und zu guter Letzt auch die Weichteile,
die Genitalien.
Da ist natürlich auch immer so,
dass dann Ende Gelände ist.
Ei ei ei! Aber wo wir gerade bei Batman sind:
Dafür haben wir
genau den richtigen Experten,
nämlich Comicfan Alper von Cinema Strikes Back.
Also Batman
debütierte 1939 in Detective Comics,
dann erschien schon recht
schnell die Batman-Reihe.
Die hatte allein schon über 700 Ausgaben.
Es gab die Crossover,
in denen er immer wieder vorkam,
die Novels, die vielen, vielen Graphic Novels und Oneshots, in denen er vorkam.
In den 40ern erschienen er sogar mal in einer Zeitung mit einem eigenen Comic.
Kurzfassung: Man braucht verdammt viel Zeit
und sehr viel Geld.
Danke, Alper. Und weil aller guten Dinge drei sind:
Im Videospiel droht Scarecrow eine Gasbombe zu zünden, die Menschen komplett durchdrehen lässt
Das kann nur die Chemikerin
meines Vertrauens beantworten.
Hier von der Uni Leipzig. Marika, was brauchen wir für so eine Bombe?
Eigentlich gar nicht so viel,
aber vor allen Dingen das.
Das kannst du ja mal aufmachen.
Aber nicht dran riechen!
- Upsi!
Geht's wieder?
Ich habe da noch zwei Fragen,
die ich gerne noch beantworten würde,
weil damals hatten wir diese coole One Piece-Folge.
Da war Synchronsprecher Marios Gavrilis mit dabei.
Und er spricht uns auch dieses Mal wieder
die Fragen ein, mit der Stimme von Katakuri.
Also bei Brook
ist das schwierig zu sagen,
weil er besteht ja nur aus Knochen.
Aber wenn wir uns das bei einem normalen
Menschen angucken wollen,
dann können wir erst mal in die Tierwelt
schauen.
Da gibt es nämlich den Basilisken,
der wird auch Jesus Christus-Echse genannt
und der kann in Gefahrensituationen
auch übers Wasser laufen.
Das macht der, indem der achtmal pro
Sekunde auf die Wasseroberfläche tritt.
Das ist superschnell, und zwar so schnell,
dass die Wassermoleküle viel zu träge sind,
um aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Und deswegen können die eben sein
Gewicht tragen.
Ein Forschungsteam hat das 1996 mal für den Menschen hoch skaliert und ausgerechnet.
Man müsste mit über 100 km/h über das
Wasser laufen, um eben nicht einzusinken.
Und das ist leider unmöglich.
Sehr gute Frage.
Kann ich ausrechnen,
wird aber kompliziert.
Das gar nicht schlimm. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Die Community hat sich nämlich explizit noch mal so eine richtig schöne Monsterformel von dir gewünscht.
Und hier ist sie!
Ja! Ergibt Sinn.
Und das Ergebnis ist.
Damit seine Füße Feuer fangen, muss er sich pro Sekunde 341 mal drehen.
Was?
Henry, Danke!
- Voll gern!
Aber damit du nicht alleine beballert wirst,
haben wir auch noch eine Frage für
unsere Lieblings-Physikerin aufgehoben.
Mit Anne haben wir nämlich schon richtig
viele schöne Folgen zusammen gemacht.
Und Anne ist ja auch ein totaler Pokémon-Nerd.
Ganz genau, und deswegen kriegt sie auch diese Frage hier.
Ich gebe zu, 1.000.000.000 Löwen sind wirklich sehr, sehr viele Löwen.
Trotzdem wird ein Pokémon auf jeden Fall gewinnen.
Hier ist ein Beispiel dafür, wie krass Pokémon nämlich sind.
Magcargo hat eine Körpertemperatur von 10.000 Grad Celsius.
Das ist einfach doppelt so viel, wie
die Oberflächentemperatur von der Sonne.
Das heißt, keiner der 1.000.000.000 Löwen
könnte Magcargo irgendwie nah kommen,
ohne Weg zu schmelzen.
Und das ist nur ein Pokémon.
Wir könnten ja auch mal
1.000.000 SpongeBobs einsetzen.
Gute Idee.
Dazu gab es nämlich auch
jede Menge Fragen, manche sogar doppelt.
Hi ich bin Techtastisch vom Kanal Techtastisch!
Und wenn ihr Feuer
unter Wasser machen wollt,
geht das sogar wirklich einfach, denn ihr müsst dafür einfach nur ein paar
Wunderkerzen zusammenhalten, denn diese
versorgen sich selbst mit Sauerstoff
durch die chemischen Verbindungen,
die drin sind und reagieren.
Und bei mehreren ist die Hitze so konzentriert, dass sich die Reaktion unter Wasser am Laufen hält.
Ganz genau diese extrem heißen
chemischen Reaktionen, wie zum Beispiel
brennende Wunderkerzen oder auch
brennendes Magnesium unter Wasser,
sind so heiß, dass sie die Wassermoleküle H2O
in Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff aufspalten können und der Sauerstoff hält die Reaktion am Laufen.
Also Feuer unter Wasser, check.
Aber wie sieht es eigentlich mit den Lebewesen bei SpongeBob aus?
Diese Fragen habe ich weitergegeben, und zwar an Meeresbiologin Julia.
Schwämme sitzen am Boden und filtern Wasser
und fressen dann Bakterien und kleine Partikel darin.
Thats it. Kein so spannendes Leben.
Patrick, dass war wohl genug Wissen für einen Tag.
Du bist frei.
Das ist Unsinn, mein lieber Junge.
Manche Seesterne verstecken sich unter
Steinen, aber schlafen
tun sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
- Danke, Julia.
Letzte Frage noch zu SpongeBob:
Also, er hier kann es.
So, erster Themenblock ist durch.
Und damit kommen wir zu einer
schönen Aufgabe für dich, Henry.
Du darfst jetzt nämlich die Leute ziehen,
die was bei uns gewonnen haben.
Dafür haben wir all eure Kommentare
in dieser wunderbaren
Glaskugel hier zusammengefasst
und wir verlosen jetzt als erstes
den Strohhut von Ruffy, passend zu One Piece
und zu Annes Frage passend,
einen süßen kleinen Pokéball.
Henry, für den Strohhut, let's go!
Und gewonnen hat ...
...
Halt’s einfach in die Kamera!
Gewinnerin Nummer 1 für den Strohhut. Vielen Dank.
Und den Pokéball kriegt
Herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Liebe Gewinner:innen,
bitte schreibt uns eine Mail an
wissen@mdr.de mit eurer Adresse,
dann senden wir euch das alles zu
und packen auch was Schönes mit drauf.
Nämlich eine Karte von dir, Henry.
Die hast du selbst gestaltet.
Und wir haben auch noch ein Gruß drauf
geschrieben aus der Redak...
Henry, wir haben doch gesagt,
da soll ein Spruch draufstehen.
Hab ich vergessen.
Kannst Du das bitte noch machen?
Ja, ich mach das jetzt.
Während Henry eure Karten hier weiter vorbereitet,
kümmern wir uns um Themenblock Nummer zwei.
Es scheint, als hätten wir sehr viele
Potter-Heads in unserer Community.
Und deswegen legen wir in diesem Themenblock einfach mal direkt los mit euren Fragen.
Ja! Schaut mal hier.
Und wer ein paar mehr PS braucht,
der nimmt einfach den Motor-Besen.
Koboldsilber sehen wir zum Beispiel hier
beim Schwert von Gryffindor.
Und ich muss gleich zugeben,
dass Aufnehmen von Dingen,
die das Material stärken,
wie zum Beispiel das Gift des Basilisken,
das gehört natürlich in die magische Welt.
Aber ein Schwert, das
zum Beispiel Schmutz und Wasser abweist,
das ist gar nicht so weit hergeholt.
Zum Beispiel mit einem Trick
bei der Bearbeitung von Metallen.
Mit Lasern kann man nämlich
filigrane Muster direkt auf die Metalloberfläche brennen.
Und diese winzig kleinen Muster,
die imitieren dann die Lamellen
der Lotuspflanze aus der Natur.
Ihr kennt sicherlich den Lotuseffekt.
Das Wasser von den Blättern der Pflanze
einfach abperlt.
Und genau das gleiche passiert hier auch.
Durch diese eingebrannten
winzig kleinen Muster bleibt Wasser,
aber auch winzig
kleine Staub- und Schmutzpartikel
dann nicht mehr auf der Metalloberfläche haften.
Ja, hier ist er.
Der goldene Schnatz!
Schön auch, dass Gandalf das fragt.
Also für diejenigen,
die die Szene nicht kennen,
Dumbledore, muss diese Flüssigkeit austrinken
und leidet dann unter ziemlich krassen
Schmerzen und Halluzinationen.
Da würde man zuerst an eine Säure oder
irgendein Gift denken,
aber es reicht schon
eine ziemlich harmlose Flüssigkeit aus,
nämlich diese hier.
Und das ist Kampferöl.
Kampferöl wird bei Erkältungen verwendet, weil es schmerlindernd und antiseptisch ist.
Aber wenn man zu große Mengen davon schluckt, dann kommt es zu Kopfschmerzen,
zu Halluzinationen und man landet am Ende im Delirium.
Also, das könnte tatsächlich ein Real-Life-Pendant sein.
Und wo wir schon bei krassen Drinks sind,
schauen wir doch gleich mal auf The Witcher.
Da hat Geralt ja diesen Trank durch den er stärker wird, schnellere Reflexe bekommt
und auch nachts besser sieht.
Wir haben direkt mal bei einer Ärtzin nachgefragt.
Florence, sag mal, geht das?
Ich würde sagen, das klingt nach einem ziemlichen Amphetamin-Cocktail, den Geralt trinkt.
Amphetamin versetzt den Körpern ja in eine Art Stress-Zustand.
ganz ähnlich wie es passiert, wenn wir in einer bedrohlichen Situation sind.
Dadurch können wir uns besser konzentrieren, können schneller Entscheidungen treffen
und sind körperlich extrem leistungsfähig.
Durch den Konsum von Amphetamin weiten sich die Pupillen.
Dadurch fällt mehr Licht ins Auge
und man kann im Dunkeln besser sehen.
Aber Geralt sollte es besser nicht so oft machen,
denn durch Amphetamine sterben die Nervenzellen nach und nach ab.
Die letzte Frage in diesem Block:
Wer könnte das besser beantworten,
als MrWissen2go höchstpersönlich?
Es gibt durchaus einige Expertinnen und Experten,
die vermuten, dass es eine Stadt
wie Atlantis gegeben haben könnte
und dass diese Stadt dann durch eine
Naturkatastrophe heimgesucht worden ist,
zum Beispiel ein Tsunami oder ein Erdbeben
und damit unter Wasser geraten ist.
Eine andere Variante wäre allerdings,
dass man sich den Ursprung dieser Geschichte anguckt.
Und das ist Platon,
der bekannte griechische Philosoph.
Und es liegt auch im Bereich des Möglichen,
dass Platon Atlantis einfach als eine Art Metapher nimmt
für überbordenden Lebensstil,
für Umwelt, für Naturzerstörung
und vieles mehr.
Und dass das eben Konsequenzen haben kann.
So ist es möglich, dass es Atlantis nie gab und sich das alles nur im Kopf
und in den Schriften
von Platon widergespiegelt hat.
Wie gesagt, so ganz weiß man's nicht, aber das macht ja auch so ein bisschen den Reiz aus, finde ich.
Danke Mirko, für diese abschließenden Worte,
denn wir sind durch mit Part zwei und es gibt wieder Gewinne, Gewinne, Gewinne!
Dieses Mal ist Godzilla im Lospot
und der Schirm von Mary Poppins.
Und den Godzilla gewinnt...
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Der Godzilla kommt zu dir.
Und der Mary Poppins Schirm geht an...
Leider kein One Piece-Artikel! Aber der Schrim geht an Dich, viel Spaß damit.
Wir haben in der Vergangenheit schon einige schaurige Videos gemacht.
Über Zombies haben wir gesprochen, über
Exorzismen und auch über die Fallen aus SAW.
Aber gerade da scheinen noch nicht
alle Fragen beantwortet zu sein.
Also wie es funktioniert,
das sieht man ja eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Diese Falle wird im Kiefer eingehackt
und wenn die Zeit abgelaufen ist,
dann reißt sie den halt
einfach auseinander.
Unappetitlich wie Sau.
Und damit genau das Richtige für den
Kriminalbiologen unseres Vertrauens, Dr. Mark Benecke.
Und der sagt, das würde gehen.
Wenn ich jetzt etwas habe, was so irgendwie zusammengeklappt ist,
dann kann das ja auch mit sehr großer Kraft auseinandergezogen werden,
ihr kriegt ja auch riesige Koffer gehoben.
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, ihr baut so ein Ding mit Spiralen und irgendwelchen
Kraftübertragungs-Einheiten aus Metall, egal wie stark der Kiefermuskel ist.
Das könnte schon gut auseinanderreißen, würde ich also nicht zu Hause ausprobieren.
Und das mit den Spiralen und Metallteilen,
das müssen wir uns nicht nur vorstellen.
Das hat natürlich auch
schon jemand nachgebaut...
Die SAW-Folge, die wir gemeinsam mit Mark gemacht haben,
die verlinke ich euch hier oben
aber natürlich auch in der Infobox,
denn wir haben noch eine zweite Folge
mit ihm gemacht, nämlich zu Kevin allein zu Haus.
Und im Vergleich zur Reverse Bear Trap sehen Kevins Fallen vielleicht unschuldiger aus...
Aber lasst euch nicht täuschen,
in Wirklichkeit sind die nämlich sau gefährlich.
Deswegen völlig zurecht die Frage:
Das haben andere YouTuber
schon nachgezählt und die Antwort lautet:
Harry müsste in den ersten beiden Teilen
neunmal sterben und Marv 14 Mal.
Und wenn wir schon bei morbiden Fragen sind, dann doch gleich noch diese hier:
Ja, das geht.
Und zwar nicht nur mit einem Katana-Schwert,
sondern mit vielen anderen Schwertern
auch.
Aber bitte, bitte,
bitte macht das nicht zu Hause nach,
denn wir brauchen eure süßen
Köpfchen noch für zwei Gehirn-Fragen,
die wir direkt mal weitergeben an Dr. Janis.
Die einzelnen kognitiven Fähigkeiten,
die Sherlock dafür braucht,
die sind durchaus möglich.
Und selbst die Techniken, die er verwendet, wie Gedächtnispaläste, gibt es wirklich
und werden auch regelmäßig von Gedächtnisweltmeistern verwendet.
Also zumindest theoretisch ist es möglich.
Praktisch ist es aber doch sehr unwahrscheinlich,
dass eine einzelne Person diese ganzen Fähigkeiten in sich vereint.
Angenommen jemand möchte mich fernsteuern, sodass mein linker Daumen zuckt.
Dann müsste man dafür hier mein Gehirn
stimulieren.
Entweder indem man da eine Elektrode implantiert
oder sogar von außen durch den Schädel
hindurch mit speziellen Magnetspulen.
Also das funktioniert.
Aber beides würde ich wohl bemerken
und unsere Gedanken
sind dann doch deutlich komplizierter
als einzelne Muskeluuckungen.
Also ganz einfache Reaktionen, ja.
Richtig Gedanken steuern? Nein.
Danke, Dr. Janis.
Und wen wir schon beim Thema Gedankenkontrolle sind,
dann lasst uns gleich noch diese Frage hier machen:
Ich liebe den Film.
Ich liebe diese Szene.
Zum einen, weil Daniel Kaluuya das so krass intensiv spielt und zum anderen,
weil das für mich als Kontrollfreak
eine absolute Horrorvorstellung ist.
Irgendjemand flippt einen Schalter
bei dir um und du kannst nichts mehr machen.
Und ich habe mich für MDR WISSEN
tatsächlich mal hypnotisieren lassen.
Und zwar von Barbara Schmidt.
Die ist Hypnose-Forscherin und arbeitet
am Universitätsklinikum in Jena.
Und an sie habe ich diese Frage
deshalb auch weitergegeben.
und sie sagt: Ja, das geht!
Das ist eine posthypnotische Suggestion.
Das heißt, dieses Geräusch
ist daran geknüpft, was er da erlebt
und kann dadurch wieder ausgelöst
werden, nur durch dieses Geräusch.
Aber es wird sehr negativ benutzt
in dem Film.
Also meine Art es zu nutzen wäre es so:  Diese Person zurückzuführen in diese Situation,
wo er so ganz paralysiert war, weil seine Mutter nicht nach Hause gekommen ist
und er wusste nicht, was er machen soll.
Und ihm dort Trost zu spenden.
Also die Hypnose positiv einzusetzen,
zum Beispiel in der Psychotherapie.
Damit kommen wir zum letzten Thema
in diesem Blog und das ist Telekinese.
Also Dinge in Bewegung versetzen
nur durch Kraft der Gedanken.
Die Frage lautet:
Also sagen wir mal so:
Seit 1987 gibt es in Deutschland
die Gesellschaft zur wissenschaftlichen
Untersuchung von Parawissenschaften.
Und die führt seit 2004 sogenannte Psi-Tests durch.
Bei diesen Tests können Menschen,
die übersinnliche Fähigkeiten haben,
10.000€ gewinnen, wenn sie diese auch beweisen.
Das Problem ist, bislang hat noch nie jemand dieses Geld bekommen,
weil noch niemand solche Fähigkeiten vorgeführt und dann wirklich auch bewiesen hat.
Das spricht jetzt erst mal nicht dafür,
dass es so etwas wie Telekinese tatsächlich gibt.
Möglichkeiten, Dinge schweben zu lassen,
gibt es in der Physik aber Gott sei Dank jede Menge.
Zum Beispiel durch Druckluft
und dem sogenannten Coanda-Effekt,
oder durch elektromagnetische Levitation, oder wie hier ganz einfach durch Schallwellen.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Schaut mal hier: Für dieses Real-Life-Hoverboard braucht es viele von diesen elektrischen Mantelstromlüftern, kurz genannt EDFs.
Und ein physikalisches Prinzip,
nämlich den Bodeneffekt.
Henry, da musst du nochmal helfen. Wie genau funktioniert der Bodeneffekt?
Vereinfacht funktioniert das so: Wenn das Hoverboard nahe über dem Boden fliegt,
ist der Boden ein Hindernis für die Luft, die von den EDFs nach unten gedrückt wird.
Die Luft kann nicht weg.
Dadurch bildet sich wie so ein Luftkissen,
auf dem das Ding schwebt.
Im Prinzip ist das wie ein Luftkissenboot.
Okay, physikalisch gibt es bei dem Ding also kein Problem.
Hier ist eher die zuverlässige Umsetzung und Anwendung die Herausforderung.
Denn es ist super schwierig, auf diesem Ding vernünftig zu balancieren.
Und auf Wasser, so wie wir das bei Zurück in die Zukunft 2 sehen,  funktioniert das Ding leider überhaupt nicht.
Und mit Zurück in die Zukunft sind wir eigentlich schon mittendrin im letzten Themenblock.
Aber vorher verlosen wir noch was, nämlich
Thors Hammer und Wolverines Klingen.
Den Hammer bekommt...
Und die Wolverine-Klingen bekommt...
Viel Spaß damit!
Kommen wir noch mal Zurück in die Zukunft.
Wir haben ja mit den Wissenschaftspodcastern  von Methodisch inkorrekt eine ganze Folge dazu gemacht.
Richtig nice im DeLorean und sogar
eine extra Folge zum Thema Zeitreisen.
Aber da sind anscheinend noch ein paar
Fragen offen geblieben, nämlich:
Super Frage! Nicolas, Reinhard,
was sagt ihr dazu?
Das ist natürlich völlig richtig. Zeitmaschinen sind absoluter Quatsch.
Eine Zeitangabe alleine reicht nicht. Wenn, dann würden wir eine Raum-Zeitmaschine bauen.
Denn Raum und Zeit sind eine Größe in im Wesentlichen. Die Raumzeit.
Zeitmaschinen sind so 1980.
Tja, Zeitreisen wird immer komplizierter.
Nächste Frage:
Ja, ja!
Und wenn euch diese Antwort zu dumm war,
dann könnten wir euch
einfach blitzdingsen, mit dem Neuralisator von Men in Black.
Tatsächlich forscht man in der Neurowissenschaft schon ziemlich lang daran,
gezielt Erinnerungen aus dem Gedächtnis zu löschen.
Und bei Ratten hat das auch schon funktioniert.
Bei denen konnte man in einem Experiment
Angsterfahrungen löschen,
indem man ihnen eine bestimmte chemische
Substanz ins Gehirn gespritzt hat.
Das ist alles noch Grundlagenforschung
und funktioniert natürlich
noch nicht so elegant und so cool
wie bei Men in Black.
Aber wenn sich aus diesen Erkenntnissen
irgendwann mal zum Beispiel
ein Medikament entwickeln lässt,
dann wäre das eine echte Erleichterung.
Nämlich für Patienten, die unter einer posttraumatischen Belastungsstörung leiden.
In den meisten Fällen geht es
aber im Bereich Hightech und Gedächtnis
nicht darum, Erinnerungen zu löschen,
sondern um das genaue Gegenteil,
also Momente abzuspeichern und festzuhalten. Zum Beispiel in digitalen Fotoalben.
Oder mit  fancy Kontaktlinsen
a la Black Mirror.
Dort wird alles, was die Augen wahrnehmen, abgespeichert und ist dann per Knopfdruck wieder aufrufbar.
Noch einen Schritt weiter
gehen wir mit der nächsten Frage.
Die beschäftigt sich mit Cyberpunk 2077,
denn dort gibt es gleich ein ganzes Augenimplantat.
Und das hat so eine integrierte Zoomfunktion.
Die Frage ist: Ist so was vorstellbar oder vielleicht schon möglich?
Und das gebe ich direkt mal weiter an
Niklas Kolorz, denn der kann alles erklären.
Als Implantat noch nicht.
Aber die Firma Mojo Vision hat 2022 einen Prototypen einer smarten Kontaktlinse vorgestellt.
Hier seht ihr den CEO, wie er sich diesen winzig kleinen LED-Bildschirm
direkt aufs Auge legt, der ist gerade mal
einen halben Millimeter dick,
bringt es aber heute schon auf
11.000 Pixel pro Zentimeter.
Und dann ist da noch ein 5Ghz-Modem
drin, ein Beschleunigungsmesser
ein Bewegungs-Sensor und auch der Akku. Das ist krass.
Bis 2077 sollte also eine simple Zoomfunktion nun wirklich kein Problem sein.
Okay, cool. Das könnte also tatsächlich Realität werden.
Vielleicht dann auch das nächste Gadget, das die Star Wars Fans unter euch beschäftigt hat.
Bei der Frage...
Also so wie das im Film dargestellt ist,
funktioniert das natürlich noch nicht.
Aber die kanadischen Tüftler von Hacksmith Industries,
haben schon vor drei Jahren dieses Real-Life-Lichtschwert hergestellt.
Das funktioniert über 2.200 Grad heißes Plasma,
das beim Entzünden von dem Gemisch
aus Sauerstoff und Propangas entsteht.
Die Gastanks kann man prinzipiell
als Rucksack auf dem Rücken tragen
und dann für fünf Minuten Gas geben.
Mit diesem Schwert lassen sich dann easy peasy Stormtrooper erledigen und selbst Stahl lässt sich damit schmelzen.
Und klar, das ist ein Prototyp und erfüllt
auch nicht eins zu eins alle Funktionen wie im Film.
Denn wenn man jetzt wirklich ein echtes
Lichtschwert haben wollten,
dann bräuchten wir viel mehr Leistung
und dafür müssten wir ja wohl erst mal
eine Real-Life-Diatium-Energiezelle erfinden.
So viel zu Lichtschwertern.
Und wenn wir die abgefrühstückt haben, dann müssen wir uns natürlich auch noch die Blaster anschauen.
Aber dafür sollten wir vielleicht noch mal kurz den Unterschied klären.
Jakob von Star Wars Stories, klär uns auf.
Wie Obi Wan bereits sagte, sind Lichtschwerter elegante Waffen aus zivisierteren Tagen.
Blaster hingegen sind eher plump und ungenau.
Beliebt bei Schurken und Kopfgeldjägern
sind sie aber auch
die primären Waffen von Klonkriegen
und Sturmtruppen.
Somit nichts für die Jedi.
Aber die Jedi werden auf jeden Fall
ständig mit Blastern beballert.
Und eine gute Frage dazu:
Okay Henry, ich glaube hier bräuchte ich nochmal. Hast du eine Idee?
Ja, das haben Physiker-Kollegen von mir
schon mal für Wired ausgerechnet.
Die haben alle 91 Blaster-Schüsse aus den Originalfilmen analysiert.
Und die Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit
von denen im Nahkampf sind 125 km/h.
Das entspricht ungefähr der Geschwindigkeit von einem Ball beim Elfmeter.
Und das könnten die Jedi auf jeden Fall
easy abblocken.
Ja, total. Und vielleicht auch eine
gute Erklärung dafür, warum Stormtrooper
einfach absolut kacke im Nahkampf sind.
Henry ich habe übrigend noch eine Gaming- Frage für dich:
Alle.
Damit hast du dich definitiv
für die nächste Frage disqualifiziert.
Physik und Astro
da kenne ich genau die Richtige.
Das geben wir weiter an Sina von Sonne, Tod und Sterne.
Also wenn sie auf Mutterschiffen
los fliegen, so in das Vakuum des Weltalls,
da sind Flügel nicht so wichtig. Das ist wahrscheinlich kein Problem.
Aber wenn sie von einem Planeten
mit Atmosphäre und Schwerkraft los starten würden,
das geht wahrscheinlich nur senkrecht wie bei Raketen.
Und ob das jetzt so ein Hamburger
wie der Millennium Falke wirklich könnte?
Ja, der bräuchte wahrscheinlich
noch ein paar Raketenstufen
und Booster, damit er am Ende nicht
wie eine Frisbee wieder runterkommt.
Und damit kommen wir zur letzten Star
Wars-Frage:
Also schon Aristoteles hat festgestellt,
dass größere Tiere länger leben als kleine.
Warum das so ist, ist biologisch relativ komplex.
Aber es gilt tatsächlich:
Große Tiere leben länger.
Aber Yoda muss sich nicht sorgen,
denn mein Lieblings-Tierarzt Karim
hat uns ein Beispiel mitgebracht, bei dem es genau umgekehrt ist.
- Hunde.
Bei Hunden leben die kleinen Exemplare
viel länger als die großen.
Das liegt an unserer menschlichen Zucht
und dem Einfluss auf die Gene von Hunden.
Also ist Yoda vielleicht ein Zucht-Experiment?
So oder so, wenn man als Machtgeist in Ethereum abhängt, ist Lebenserwartung krass irrelevant.
In diesem Sinne: Möge die Macht und ein hohes Alter mit euch sein.
Und damit meine fellow Trekkies
jetzt nicht zu kurz kommen,
gibt es für euch noch die Frage,
die euch am meisten beschäftigt hat...
Jein! Also in der Realität funktioniert
das mit ganz kleinen Dingen
tatsächlich schon, mit Menschen
allerdings noch nicht.
Und selbst wenn es irgendwann mal gehen sollte
ich würde das auf keinen Fall machen, denn man stirbt dabei.
Denkt mal drüber nach,
ihr werdet ja zerstört
und jemand anderes, ein Klon von euch
wird quasi woanders wieder aufgebaut.
Ja, mit euren Gedanken und Erinnerungen. Aber das seid dann nicht mehr ihr.
Ihr seid dann tot.
Zugegeben, das klingt jetzt noch nicht so
wirklich cool,
aber anyway. Ihr wolltet noch wissen:
Also zugegeben, ich bin eher Team
Star Trek als Team Star Wars,
weil, wenn wir ehrlich sind,
Star Wars ist halt keine richtige Science
Fiction Space Magic.
Aber anyway. Mein Favorit ist sowieso was
anderes, nämlich die Trilogie von Zurück in die Zukunft.
Ich bin der Größte Zurück in die Zukunft-Fan in Deutschland.
- Okay.
Dann lass uns doch mal auf Serien schauen,
denn da ist mein Favorit tatsächlich
das moderne Update von Doc Brown
und Marty McFly, nämlich die beiden...
Und nun zum krönenden Abschluss
die Frage aller Fragen:
Was ist die Antwort auf alles? 42!
Das schreibt Douglas Adams
einfach so frech in seinem Buch.
Das muss uns jetzt mal
Susanne von Mathematrik erklären.
Dann schauen wir doch mal, ob wir ein paar schöne Eigenschaften der Zahl 42 finden können.
Die Binärdarstellung sieht schon mal sehr schön aus.
Außerdem ist sie eine Catalan-Zahl. Das sind Zahlen, die in der Kombinatorik eine wichtige Rolle spielen.
Und es gibt unter einer Million nur 14 Stück.
Die Primfaktorzerlegung ist jetzt nicht sonderlich spannend.
Ansonsten wird es dann auch schon ein bisschen dünn.
Sie kommt noch in meinem Autokennzeichen vor. Vielleicht reicht das.
Und apropos Autokennzeichen.
In der finalen Gewinnauslosung haben wir
dieses wunderbare Batmobil, Marke Tumbler, und den süßen kleinen Groguuuu.
Wegen der ganzen Star Wars Fragen.
Henry, bist Du fertig? Dann los, komm her. Du darfst noch mal ziehen.
Also, wer kriegt das Batmobil?
Und Groguuuu...
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Ihr bekommt diese beiden Sachen nach Hause geschickt.
Henry, das war ein wilder Ritt durch die Fragen in aller Kürze.
Auch wenn wir leider nicht alle beantworten konnten.
Ja, das macht nichts.
Wir haben ja auch ganz viele Expertinnen
und Experten, die uns hier Rede
und Antwort gestanden haben.
Und die machen ja weiter Content.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass die das
in ihren Videos auch mal auflösen werden.
Also folgt denen bitte.
Wir packen die ganzen Handels
und Verlinkungen unten in die Infobox.
Und für uns auch gerne
noch ein Abo oder ein Like da lassen.
Denn jetzt ist eh alles egal und es sind
so viele schöne Videos noch da.
Teilt die, spreaded das noch ein bisschen.
Und wir sagen jetzt an dieser Stelle
im Namen des gesamten
Science vs. Fiction Teams und von der Redaktion MDR WISSEN:
Danke, dass ihr uns so lange die Treue gehalten habt.
Danke, für die ganze Liebe in den
Kommentaren und für euch alles Gute!
Rutscht gut ins neue Jahr!
Liebe Grüße aus Leipzig
Und man sieht sich!
Komm, wir drücken uns noch einmal.
Du riechst aber gut!
- Gehen wir noch einen Glühwein trinken?